en el vídeo anterior yo les comenté que
si conocíamos el cambio en distancia
delta de si conocíamos también la
aceleración y conocíamos la velocidad
inicial entonces mi pregunta era cómo
podríamos encontrar la velocidad final
durante ese vídeo llegamos a la
siguiente fórmula si no se acuerdan les
recomiendo que vean ese segundo vídeo la
velocidad final al cuadrado es igual a
la velocidad inicial al cuadrado más 2
veces el cambio en la distancia
recordemos que este término lo podemos
encontrar como distancia cuando asumimos
que la distancia inicial es cero así que
la diferencia en distancia es igual a la
distancia final pero podemos usarlas
indistintamente espero que a estas
alturas se den cuenta de por qué sigo
cambiando entre los términos distancia y
diferencia en distancia pues para que
ustedes se familiaricen con ambos esta
es la fórmula para cuando no sabemos
cuál es la velocidad final pero ahora
queremos encontrar el tiempo ahora
queremos encontrar el tiempo cuando
encontramos la velocidad final podemos
encontrar el tiempo y luego les mostraré
cómo hacerlo pero ahora veamos cómo
encontrar el tiempo cuando tenemos los
datos como el cambio en distancia de la
aceleración y la velocidad inicial
regresamos a nuestra fórmula básica de
distancia como se relaciona la distancia
de la velocidad
el cambio en distancia entre el cambio
en tiempo el cambio en el tiempo van a
ser iguales a la velocidad promedio y
esto implica que el cambio en distancia
el cambio en distancia va a ser igual a
la velocidad promedio por el cambio en
el tiempo o lo que es lo mismo distancia
es igual a velocidad por el tiempo y
esto es para cuando no está distancia
inicial es cero y para cuando nuestro
tiempo inicial es igual a cero entonces
tenemos estos datos cambian distancia la
aceleración la velocidad inicial quiero
encontrar el tiempo asumiendo que el
tiempo inicial es igual a cero re
escribo aquí abajo mi fórmula y ahora
voy a sustituir la velocidad promedio
asumiendo que tenemos una aceleración
constante que es la gravedad
a velocidad inicial más velocidad final
entre 2 y esto es cuando asumimos que
tenemos una aceleración constante que es
la gravedad y eso lo multiplicamos por
el tiempo no podemos usar esta fórmula
directamente porque no conocemos la
velocidad final vamos a tratar de
calcular está en términos de los otros
datos que tenemos y entonces quizá
podamos calcular el tiempo que sabemos
de la velocidad final bueno sabemos que
el cambio en la velocidad
la diferencia de velocidad es igual a la
aceleración por el tiempo a su vez la
diferencia en velocidad es la velocidad
final menos la velocidad inicial que
sigue siendo igual a la aceleración por
el tiempo y ahora vamos a despejar la
velocidad final voy a pasar la velocidad
inicial sumando en ambos lados de esta
igualdad me va a quedar que la velocidad
final
es igual a la velocidad inicial
más la aceleración por el tiempo y ahora
esta velocidad final la voy a sustituir
aquí
de manera que me va a quedar distancia
es igual
velocidad inicial más velocidad final
que a su vez la velocidad final es esta
velocidad inicial más la aceleración por
el tiempo todo esto entre 2 y a su vez
todo esto es multiplicado por el tiempo
bueno vamos a simplificar esto la
distancia es igual a velocidad inicial
más velocidad inicial dos veces
velocidad inicial más la aceleración por
el tiempo entre dos por el tiempo y
ahora vamos a distribuir este en estos
términos me va a quedar que es tracy
igual 2 velocidad e iniciará entre 2 me
va a quedar igual a velocidad inicial
por el tiempo más la aceleración por el
tiempo por el tiempo es el tiempo al
cuadrado aceleración por tiempo al
cuadrado entre 2 y aquí tengo la
distancia es igual a la velocidad
inicial por el tiempo más la aceleración
por el tiempo al cuadrado entre 2
también lo puedo describir como el
cambio en la distancia igual la
velocidad inicial por tiempo más la
aceleración por el tiempo al cuadrado
entre 2 vamos a hacer un resumen pues
ahora tenemos un arsenal de todas las
fórmulas que podría necesitar para
resolver problemas de movimiento de
proyectiles en una dimensión el
movimiento en una dimensión se refiere a
las cosas que se mueven ya sea de este a
oeste de izquierda a derecha de arriba a
abajo pero no en ambas eso lo veremos en
otra serie así que hagamos un resumen de
todo lo que sabemos y para esto vamos a
hacer espacio para escribir las fórmulas
sabemos que el cambio en distancia entre
el cambio en el tiempo
va a ser igual a la velocidad promedio
siempre y cuando tengamos una
aceleración constante aceleración
constante también sabemos que el cambio
en la velocidad entre el cambio en el
tiempo va a ser igual a la aceleración
sabemos que la velocidad promedio es
igual a la velocidad final más la
velocidad inicial entre 2
también con aceleración constante esto
solamente con aceleración constante
sabemos que la velocidad final al
cuadrado es igual a la velocidad inicial
al cuadrado más dos veces la aceleración
por el cambio en la distancia o la
distancia aquí pongo el cambio en
distancia porque a veces si importa cuál
es el cambio en la distancia a veces no
comenzamos con una distancia igual a
cero y también sabemos que la distancia
es igual a la velocidad inicial por el
tiempo más la aceleración por el tiempo
al cuadrado entre 2 y en el siguiente
vídeo continuaremos resolviendo este
problema para encontrar el tiempo